eu gostaria de pedir para vocês todos
estão aqui que fechassem os olhos por
uns momentos
imaginem vocês estão almoçando com
pessoas que vocês ano os seus filhos com
seu marido com sua esposa e no meio do
almoço você de repente não sabe onde
você está
você não reconhece a sua casa você não
reconhece o seu marido seus filhos e sua
esposa ninguém lembra os olhos
é desesperador parece um pesadelo
faz quatro meses que eu passei por isso
eu estava dando almoço pros meus filhos
e de repente não sabia quem era o meu
marido quem eram meus filhos onde eu
estava e foi internada e eu achei minha
mente voltou ao ano de 2002
eu achava que eu tinha um filho de três
meses quando ele tem 11 anos
eu não sabia que eu tinha mais dois
filhos eo novo marido e quando estava no
hospital eu chamava pelo meu ex marido
vai me tirar daqui
cadê você que nunca tocam eu preciso de
você
o curioso é que a gente não se falava
muito bem há sete anos e eu falava eu te
amo vem pra cá me salvar
e daí alguns médicos falaram pra minha
família que eles teriam que me internar
por tempo indeterminado
consegui convencer minha mãe não fazer
isso e prometi que eu ia tomar a
medicação pra recordar as coisas
depois de um mês eu percebi que a
medicação não estava me ajudando em nada
que eu estava simplesmente é tapada um
só sente absolutamente ficava em branco
não me recordava nada era cada vez mais
desesperador tudo isso eu falei eu estou
sentindo que a minha memória vai voltar
do meu jeito
vou fazer uma experiência científica com
meu próprio corpo ou escutar o meu corpo
porque eu tô sentindo que ao escutar
algumas músicas bem memórias da minha
cabeça
ao sentir alguns cheiros algumas imagens
vem na minha cabeça
então eu pedi para minha família a
separar
algumas alguns amigos aleatoriamente
amigos antigos amigos recentes e que eu
entrasse nesse lugar de olhos vendados
então eu cheguei e eu perguntava para as
pessoas vinham por vez eu perguntava
quem sou eu pra você ea primeira pessoa
foi a anl e ela falava você leitora
a gente trabalha junto a gente faz
coisas juntas
e então eu segurava na mão dela enquanto
eu escutava viam imagens na minha cabeça
eu falava as imagens que vêm pra mim é o
isp setec é o sentimento que eu tenho
por você é de muita amizade mas eu não
sei quem você é e eu pensei eu preciso
cheirá-la então vou por aí fungando as
pessoas há quatro meses
imediatamente eu tirei a anl eu falei o
nome dela foi o iml e todo mundo começou
a chorar porque foi a primeira pessoa
que eu reconheci no re pessoas físicas
reconhecer ml e outros amigos que
estavam ali também né isso foi muito
emocionante para mim porque eu vi que eu
simplesmente tem que escutar o meu corpo
escutar a minha memória sensorial
escutar meu coração e é assim que eu me
guiando nesses últimos meses me guiando
pelo que eu sinto não deixando a minha
mente mentir pra mim eu comecei a me
questionar do que nós somos realmente
para as pessoas porque hoje as pessoas
contam a história da minha vida pra mim
nos últimos 11 anos eu percebi que eu
a única coisa que eu sou a minha
essência está na memória das pessoas um
dia isso aqui não vai existir mais mas
vai ficar essência o que eu provoquei
que sentimento que eu deixei para cada
pessoa
eu comecei a pensar muito sobre isso eu
já tinha uma consciência de qual é o meu
legado para os meus filhos e para as
próximas gerações mas eu não tinha idéia
do impacto e nós temos na memória das
pessoas e cada uma em cherbourg história
de uma forma diferente é muito engraçado
porque elas vão contando coisas da minha
vida eu fico rindo eu acho que comigo
até as tragédias que já
nazário falou que está tudo bem e é uma
coisa muito linda que aconteceu foi o
amor transbordante de todo mundo
quando soube disso eu não tinha idéia
que no futuro o que pra mim era 2013 no
futuro já que a minha mente estava em
2002 que no futuro as pessoas são tão
gentis e tão amáveis e que existe
amizade virtual eu não tinha idéia de
que existe amizade virtual e realmente
existe então eu comecei a receber
centenas de cartas do mundo inteiro
mensagens presentes e eu tenho recebido
presentes de pessoas que eu não conheço
ontem recebi se colar de uma pessoa que
me conhece pela internet e ela fez
escolar e pediu para usar que ela disse
que me dá sorte hoje
escolar representa a minha memória
fragmentada e ficando aqui no núcleo
somente o que importa
e ele está aberto para todos que possam
chegar essa interpretação do colar
então eu tenho recebido muito disso e
tenho certeza que toda essa emoção toda
essa força que as pessoas têm mandado
mudou a minha vida ea minha relação com
minha família então pessoas que antes
eram meus desafetos viraram amigos eu
pude perdoar e eu pude ser perdoada
pessoas que eram meus amigos viraram
irmãos meus irmãos viraram meus anjos da
guarda não tinha muito contato com eles
eu pude reconectar com a minha família
meu marido que teve que escutar eu
falando do ex-marido vm salvo eu te amo
mana e ele dava instrução proes falando
olha ela gosta disso ela gosta daquilo
fale isso olha aquilo que ela vai sentir
bem
ele é eu tive a sorte de casar com meu
anjo da guarda
meus filhos viraram meus heróis e eu
tinha muito medo de como eu ia criá los
novamente porque eu me sentia
completamente inapta como mãe
de repente minha mente voltou aos 21
anos de quando tinha um bebê de três
meses e aí eu vejo um menino de 11 uma
de quase 51 de quase 3 e eu é muito pra
mim é muito isso
minha mãe se transformando em uma deusa
do olimpo pra mim ela foi a pessoa que
mais sofreu e que esteve do meu lado o
tempo inteiro e hoje ela não pode vir
aqui porque ela tá cuidando dos meus
filhos ela falou alguém tem que ser
responsável nessa família mas eu faço um
vestido pra você poder ir lá falar e não
ficar parecendo uma hip o tempo inteiro
eu tá bom vou brincar e ela passou uma
madrugada inteira fazendo esse vestido
pra mim então é como usar o dinheiro
aqui comigo também
eu aprendi que na minha vida nesses
últimos 11 anos eu tive muitas
experiências relacionadas à dor de forma
trágica para entender o que é o amor
e tem muita gente aprende de uma forma
tranquila sobre as experiências na vida
na minha sempre acontece em verdadeiras
tragédias para o despertar para as
coisas então eu descobri que eu amo a
liberdade graças eu tenho voltado para
são paulo saído de recife com o bebê no
colo com três meses e terminaram um
casamento de quatro meses sem dinheiro
no bolso sem parentes importantes lindo
bem e chegar aqui e à universidade que
me contratar que ficou seis meses sem me
pagar então eu aprendi a ser
empreendedora com isso
depois eu aprendi que a gente deve
tentar e tentar nunca desisti do que a
gente quer desfrutar do caminho quando
eu perdi algumas gravidezes e mesmo
assim insistindo e desfrutando do
caminho
nasceu meu terceiro filho davi
então eu aprendi o que é dormir o que é
comer respirar e olhar as estrelas
depois que eu tive um pai enfartou no
passado e principalmente aprendi o que é
receber ajuda e aceitar ajuda
depois que eu tive amnésia
esse foi meu grande aprendizado de toda
essa história até agora eu sei que
muitos outros aprendizados viram uma das
coisas que que foram mais impactantes
pra mim foi meu filho meu filho de de 11
anos fala pra mim mãe não se preocupa
que você não se lembra de tudo o que é
você acha que você não tem conhecimento
o conhecimento está dentro de você
a gente começa tudo de novo minha filha
de 4 anos colocava a mãozinha assim na
minha orelha e falava em piripiri
entende você vai se lembrar de mim
e eu falava que eu já me lembro de você
ela é então qual é a minha cor favorita
eu rosa ela não amarelo e ela não tem
problema em uma hora você vai lembrar de
mim eu tenho certeza eu estou filha ela
não mente mais que eu sei quando você
mente é feio mentir mamãe você me
ensinou isso eu tá bom filho bom nome
eu achava eu criei um projeto que se
chama escola com asas baseado inspirado
no meu filho quando eu tirei ele da
escola eu morava em barcelona e meu
filho sofria bullying na escola
18 anos ele falou pra mim mãe a minha
missão na vida é salvar crianças através
da alimentação saudável e é isso que eu
vou fazer
só que a escola não vai me ajudar nisso
e eu não quero perder tempo
então ele pediu pra eu dedicar tempo
para ensiná lo a tirar da tirada da
escola eu fui aprender tudo sobre
homeschooling schooling como é que como
é que esse movimento pedir seis meses
pra ele pra me preparar para isso e daí
surgiu a escola com as graças à
inspiração da experiência dele é e
depois foi ampliado e hoje mais de duas
mil famílias utilizam escola com asas
que é simplesmente um projeto para
empoderar as famílias que elas escutem
os seus filhos o que eles querem fazer
que não tentem direcionar o caminho
deles porque eles já sabem o que eles
querem jazz eles já estão prontos eles
só precisam que as asas deles não sejam
cortadas então nesse processo de 37
empreendimentos que eu tinha e por isso
que eu tive amnésia de dormir é três
horas por noite nos últimos cinco anos
eu não cuidava do meu corpo eu
simplesmente não parava de trabalhar e
cuidar de crianças e fazer projetos no
mundo inteiro eu resgatei meu sonho de
infância e eu tenho contado essa
história para os meus filhos para eles
entenderem qual era o meu sonho era uma
vez uma menina de 9 anos que ela não
concebia a idéia de não falar com todas
as pessoas do mundo
ela não conseguia idéia de que poderia
haver uma pessoa de outro país ela não
de se comunicar com essa criança em
outra língua
e essa menina ela nunca desistiu desse
sonho
ela só estava esperando o momento certo
com a tecnologia certa para poder fazer
isso acontecer quando eu fui para o
barcelona
comecei a estudar futuros comecei a
estudar cenários de futuros 2024 2044
2084 tudo o que está na mente da
população do imaginário ao real através
tanto dos inovadores que estão
construindo as inovações quanto do que é
conhecido como popularmente as massas o
que as massas pensam que a grande
maioria das pessoas pensam sobre o
futuro
e nessa minha busca por entrevistar as
pessoas inovadoras do mundo
eu estava no trem e eu estava com esse
caderninho aqui anotando o nome das
pessoas que eu já tinha entrevistado e
aqui no final eu coloquei buscar um
homem que vê as cores conson o primeiro
homem sai borg do mundo que uniu
harbison ele não ele não enxerga cores
ele
ele desenvolveu um chip onde ele
implantou no crânio e esse chip ele
traduz as cores em som
então ele tem uma haste aqui uma câmera
ea câmera vai fazendo assim e vai
tocando se amarelo é fá escuta fato ele
sabe que é amarela
eu precisava muito entrevistá lo porque
ele é uma das pessoas mais inovadoras do
mundo e eu estava sentada no treino
anotando isso buscar mil harbinson e ele
diz ele
há 20 anos ele pega o mesmo trem ele
entra no mesmo vagão e 60 no mesmo lugar
e que nesse momento ele saiu do vagão
dele numa das estações entrou no meu
vagão e sentou na minha frente e disse
que eu só fiz assim meu caro isso ele é
um cara que viaja o mundo tempo inteiro
não é fácil encontrar com ele ele mora
em barcelona também eu tenho prova disso
porque ele anotou o nome dele mil
raymison telefone e mail dele
e aqui embaixo já marquei entrevista com
ele que foi em março de 2012
entrevistando ravi só contei meu sonho
para ele e falei
toda vez que eu tenho que ir para a
áfrica toda vez que eu tenho que ir para
os estados unidos ou para qualquer outro
país que sempre coloca um tradutor e que
resumem tudo que eu tô falando
obviamente foi uma tagarela eles não
passa a mensagem que eu preciso que seja
passada
então eu falei pra ele eu quero
desenvolver um chip para implantar o meu
crânio e que seja um tradutor simultâneo
e que não tem mais barreiras de
comunicação com ninguém e eu não quero
isso só pra mim eu quero liberar minha
patente para a humanidade
para quem quiser utilizar ele falou que
eu te ajuda a realizar esse sonho
então ele movimentou nesse projeto
acabei desenvolvendo toda a arquitetura
toda parte do que precisa ter a
tecnologia que na verdade a tecnologia
já existe um treino em uma tecnologia
nova já existe a tecnologia de tradução
de línguas simplesmente está sendo
colocada no chip e esse tipo ele vai ser
implantado no meu crânio no crânio mas
poderia ser qualquer lugar a qualquer
osso na verdade mas eu pedi pressa no
crânio para ter comunicação mais rápido
com o ouvido
então por exemplo se você falar em
chinês comigo eu vou dar uma ordem para
o meu chip falar de ienes
tudo o que você fala comigo em chinês o
meu chip vai traduzir para mim em
português e na hora de responder pra
você em chinês
obviamente que eu não vou falar chinês
ainda ainda mas eu vou ter um alta voz
um alto-falante aqui um colar como esse
mas com alto falante e o chip ele vai
traduzir o que eu falar em português e
em chinês no mesmo momento
isso poderia ser um ep no celular
poderia mas eu quero ter a tecnologia no
meu corpo a pessoa saiba que as pessoas
que se sentem saibamos elas querem essa
mistura entre tecnologia e a parte
humana o orgânica ou para reparar
sentidos que é o caso do harrison é uma
reparação de um sentido ou aviação de um
sentido no caso ele escuta cores ou que
é o meu caso
de ampliar conhecimento ou habilidade em
2030 2040 vocês vão poder comprar chips
e pedir por um tatuador uma pessoa que
tem um lugar pequenininho implantar em
você como hoje tem tatuagem como hoje se
coloca silicone ou seja se imaginem que
há 70 anos atrás dos falastrões nossas
avós então a gente vai no médico colocou
a bolsa de silicone nos hits né
com certeza ela falaria como porque
daria todo aquele estranhamento
pode ser que hoje as pessoas vejam isso
com de uma forma estranha mas é isso
daqui a 30 anos no máximo vai ser uma
coisa super comum de acontecer as
pessoas vão ter chip pra ter um gps na
cabeça ela se perde o tempo todo eu já
estou na fila pra esse eu queria
compartilhar com vocês principalmente
para mostrar que a gente sempre pode
recomeçar do zero
a gente sempre pode realizar os nossos
sonhos desde que a gente não se veja
sozinho no mundo e não queria competir
com as outras pessoas
eu não sou engenheiro de tecnologia eu
simplesmente estou pedindo para que
outras pessoas especialistas esses
assuntos elas possam me ajudar a
realizar meu sonho
então meu filho trabalha assim na escola
com as asas nós trabalhamos assim
mostramos que todos somos
interdependentes eu sou uma coisa você
em outras você em outra e você em outra
ea gente pode se ajudar para avançar à
humanidade para evoluir como espécie
eu acredito firmemente que as crianças
já sabem que elas querem que elas vieram
fazer aqui e que a gente só precisa não
cortar as suas asas
eu agradeço imensamente pela minha mãe
nunca teve o corpo cortado as minhas
obrigado